AGI is when computers get better at
humans at every single task that go at
chess are driving a talking thinking
dreaming sleeping whatever one of the
areas that everyone has always thought
would be safe was the creative jobs fast
forward to today like not so fast the
robots can write a symphony they can
create a masterpiece we will have
billion dollar companies created with
only one employee absolutely Bitcoin was
created by one individual probably
Satoshi Nakamoto who I think was Elon
Musk yeah yeah if you think about
lawyers there are companies that are
trying to predict how a case is gonna do
you have ai algorithms predicting if you
have skin cancer or not every industry
is going to be helped by AI are there
risks that you've identified that maybe
people aren't thinking about yeah all
right guys bang bang I'm here with
Giuliano uh I thought a great place to
start this conversation would be around
Lambda which for those that don't know
uh there's been a bunch of debate and
controversy uh is this computer program
sentient Is it alive is it intelligent
walk us through uh whether have humans
actually created a computer program that
is alive and smarter than us yeah so
let's just go over how Lambda works
right so Lambda is a neural network and
a neural network is basically a
representation of how our brain brings
work but it's just a basically simple
math it's basically matrix
multiplication okay
and you realize matrix multiplication is
not simple math to somebody like me
but for computers it's very very simple
right uh
um so how Lambda works is basically you
train with you know a lot of text and
you create this big big neural network
that's just taking basically you know uh
taxes input and generating the next uh
word
um and and you're just taking input all
this data yeah then basically building
this neural net and then that neural net
is kicking out outputs and almost like a
predictive way or is it simply trying to
synthesize is it sifting through it and
looking for something or is it more so
trying to predict some outcome yeah so
it's trying to predict the next word uh
it's usually how how these neural
networks work
um but the funny thing is that like
there was this Google AI engineer that
thought that okay we can create actually
a computer that is sentient because he
talked to it he wrote some text and and
the computer wrote some texts back
um and it fooled the engineer
uh it fooled the engineer saying that it
was actually sentient so the engineer is
literally sitting there almost like if I
type into Google and it does give me
answers but it gives me links to other
uh websites or other other services the
engineer was almost like in like a chat
and it was like literally like talking
rather than you being on the other side
of the chat and responding the computer
was chatting back and the engineer
literally was like the computer has a
mind of its own it's alive like holy
[ __ ] exactly and the funny thing is that
the engineer thought that it was
sentient because it convinced the
engineer that it was sentient because
the engineer asked are you sentient
[Laughter]
that's why the engineer thought that it
was alive because it literally just
asked like visit are you alive yeah
exactly and and the funny thing is that
it's basically grabbing text from the
internet right and figuring out the
relationship between different words and
and seeing which words are connected to
others when you look at texting the
internet on Reddit and and you know like
on Google and whatnot you would see
words that are similar to what what the
engineer was asking and if you ask the
computer if like to prove that it was
not sentient the computer would also
prove that it was not sentient and the
engineer would be full that thinking
that the computer was not sentient right
so this brings us to a question of like
this idea of being sentient right like
what are the ways that Engineers think
about like when would it be sentient
versus oh no it's just predicting it's
just answering with questions off of the
internet like what is the difference in
a computer program between it actually
being sentient versus just simply uh
really really good at using machine
learning or artificial intelligence yeah
personally I think it's more a
philosophical question okay right than
than a technical question uh there's all
all these questions of like
Consciousness and and sentient if a
computer is sentient but if you actually
look at animals uh there's a very clear
correlation between the number of
neurons in our brain and how and its
cognitive ability
so if you look at you know mammals in
general the number of neurons in the
neocortex is very very predictive of
their ability to do things and that's
why humans are like much better doing
tasks than chimps and you know other
memos is because we have so many neurons
in our brain and one interesting aspect
of humans like the reason why we have so
many neurons in your neocortex is
because we develop fire
um and that's one of the reasons why you
see so many people talking about meat
because instead of digesting all these
resources in your gut you know but you
can actually break down the proteins
outside of our body and actually it
consume all these resources and produce
that many resources to our brain because
our brain needs a lot of resources
so the whole idea is that like as a
human being one our brains are highly
dense in the terms of uh neurons uh
which is equivalent in a computer
program the more neurons or or uh kind
of you know uh pieces of the neural net
yeah uh the more dense it is obviously
the more valuable it could be
um but also there's ways to use external
forces uh or uh materials to change our
body physiologically right if we eat
really bad it doesn't just make us fat
it also can have an effect on our brain
you're sluggish or tired 100 you lose
your intellectual sharpness like all
that type of stuff if you eat really
healthy there is literally a way to kind
of clear out the cobwebs if you will uh
from from a brain standpoint uh and
perform better with more mental Clarity
more kind of high performance
intelligence all that type of stuff yeah
100 and if you actually look at other
animals right uh the bigger they were
the bigger their brains are so if you
look at gorillas they have bigger brains
compared to other chimps and even like
an elephant has a big big brain but most
of their brain uh like the biggest part
of
uh the biggest part of elephant's brain
is in their motor cortex and so they can
do really good things like they can
actually do physical things really well
that's why you see elephants in circles
right and what happened is that at some
point in human evolution and in memo
Evolution we we develop fire and we
could actually break down proteins and
create so many like neurons in our brain
impact then and actually eat a lot of
food and eat a lot of resources and
actually use those resources for our
brain
the same thing is true for for computers
the bigger the neural networks the
better they perform and it's interesting
uh our brain has around 100 billion
neurons and if and if you look at the
best neural networks today they have
around the same number of neurons why is
it that if we have a hundred billion
neurons and these neural networks have a
very similar number why is it that
humans in some capacity is still much
more intelligent than the computer
systems and I'm assuming that just
computation right the computers are
better at other things but is there just
some other way to evaluate their neural
Nets other than just like the density of
the actual net itself uh and it's
missing something that doesn't actually
make it sentient or have the ability to
compete with the human brain yeah uh
that's an interesting question
so if you actually look at how we
represent or like each neuron uh in the
com in our computer system they are very
very simple compared to our neurons so
maybe we don't map one to one it could
be maybe a hundred neurons represent one
of our brain neurons but if you actually
look at different tasks right so if you
look at goal uh if you look at poker if
you look at chess computers perform
better than humans that these tasks in
when a computer is better than humans at
let's say poker go uh even chess is it
because there is a set parameter I kind
of think of it like uh bowling yeah
right like like it has the bumpers and
so like it's kind of hard to go without
outside of it and if you give a computer
set parameters and even though a chess
board as an example has many different
moves you can make there's only so many
combinations and if the computer
understands all of that then the
computer is able to just compute at a
faster Pace than the human and
understand what to do your intuition is
right okay so
one thing is that
computers do really well at games and
why why do I think that's true
it's because games are simulated
environments so you can play around and
and train your computer through many
years of training compared to humans
right but
the universe of possibilities in a go
engine is really really big uh in a gold
game so if you look at a goal game
they're more
positions in a goal game than their
atoms in the universe wow even though
it's a very simple game
it it's actually
like there's a huge number of
possibilities there are more possibility
like possible scenarios in a go game
than there are atoms in the universe
yeah that's that is a mind [ __ ] like
that is insane yeah
um and if you look at other games you
know like Alpha
um Starcraft right we have game engines
uh that perform better than humans
that's Starcraft or Dora uh so these are
very complex systems right even though
the rules are simple they're very
complex systems and I would argue the
reason why we do much better is because
you can simulate the environment and you
can play around so many times and if you
actually look at robots that perform
really well you simulate the
environments before so
um open AI which is a research
company based in Silicon Valley they
develop a robot hand that plays Rubik's
cubes and it can actually solve it
pretty fast and the way they did it is
that they simulated the the environment
before they trained the hand in this
simulated environment many many times
and the hard part was to actually
transform that into the real world
um and I think so the computer
theoretically could solve the Rubik's
Cube well before they had built a hand
to actually do it and once they were
like okay cool the computer knows how to
solve this problem then you've got to
translate it from Pure software into the
physical ability to move the Rubik's
Cube exactly and that was according to
people that I know worked there uh
it was the hardest part to transform
that from software to hardware and you
actually
I I think Tesla now will eventually have
the the best self-driving cars and their
self-driving cars will be better than
humans probably this year next year
um and I think one of the missing pieces
that they they had was to simulate the
environment right they didn't have a
simulated environment where they can
create all all these scenarios that you
wouldn't necessarily see all the time
right you have this long tail of of
um
of possibilities that you wouldn't see
necessarily in the real world but you
still want to train the computer
um and even though there are a million
you know Teslas out there and they are
grabbing data a lot of data is still not
enough because there will be there will
be scenarios where you didn't see that
scenario before and you want to train
and and and figure out what's you know
what you want to do and that's a big
that's one of the missing pieces for
computers to you know reach what they
call AGI I think
that's one like very important missing
piece right now when we train computers
we need a lot of data right so if you
look at
um Dali uh which is this computer that
basically you type it out a sentence so
let's say a koala dunking uh uh into a
uh a basketball uh
you can transform that sentence into an
image right so it's a text to image and
this is the engine to do it exactly and
the way they did it is that they grabbed
400 million image captions so that's a
lot of data right to train the system
the way humans work is that we actually
learn through a lot of data but after
some time we don't need that much data
so what do I mean by we learn we learn
by seeing a lot of data you take a long
long time to learn basic things when
you're a baby you're seeing the world
and you're reacting to it but eventually
you don't need that much data to learn
new things and one example uh that
people usually refer to is you don't
need to drive a thousand times out of a
cliff to know that you can't drive out
of a cliff and why is that is because we
actually imagine that situation right
and is that the equivalent that's the
human equivalent of a similar of a
simulation exactly exactly and if we go
and we look at uh so let's go back to
the chess example if uh I'm a chess
player I recently talked to a grand
master uh and he was talking about he
played two hours a day every day for you
know eight ten years read a lot so not
just playing but also reading through
different scenarios it removes different
responses to those moves uh studying
historical games all these different
things
how many games or how long would it take
a human to be able to get the same
amount of reps that the computer could
just simulate it seems like the computer
is much more efficient much faster and
therefore on a compounding scale it
should run away from kind of the
intelligence that the human has in a
game like chess yeah so that's a very
good question
so if you actually look at go I think
the go engine that beats the best player
uh trained for a thousand human years
and how long do we know did it take to
train the Thousand human years for the
computer oh I I don't think months years
yeah less than months right
um so pretty quickly we were able to
pack a thousand years of a one human
playing go into a couple of weeks yeah
at most and that's what people don't
realize right we learn through like we
pass
knowledge through generations so if you
look at go for example there were like
three major developments in Gold history
and they've learned new techniques and
that was passed down right so you have
this
um
this teacher student kind of knowledge
passed down through generations and
that's through through history right so
we don't only learn
In Our Lifetime we actually learn what
our parents and grandparents passed down
to us and computers can learn much
faster than that right because can they
can simulate all of that and one of the
missing pieces for robots is that they
need to actually do the simulation and
that's that's what Tesla is doing right
now right they can simulate all these
scenarios and simulate a thousand years
of driving yeah so let's take Tesla as
an example uh if you it used to be just
in Silicon Valley now across the country
people will see uh the Google car drive
by and it's got the big thing at top of
the uh vehicle and it's spinning around
uh and you don't know many times is it
like they're collecting data for Google
Maps is it the self-driving car if
you're in tune with the differences then
maybe okay that's the self-driving car
and they're obviously driving with a
human behind the driving yeah uh behind
the steering wheel to capture data like
that is what that car is doing uh and
that was a pretty cool idea it was like
let's put a bunch of cars on the Road
and capture that data we'll have our
employees behind it and over time
hopefully we can get to the point where
we could create self-driving cars make
sense
Tesla is like well why do we have to
have Tesla cars why don't we just have
everyone who drives a Tesla collect the
data for us when they're just driving
around the road we'll just collect every
single piece of data yeah and so I don't
know if that's one to a thousand one to
a million you know difference but
obviously Tesla is collecting way more
data than Google or anybody else
but what you're saying is it's not just
about collecting the data from the cars
on the road they're then taking that and
then they're running additional
simulations on top of it to even
accelerate the learning faster yeah
that's right and they started doing that
recently they started doing that I think
last year or two this year okay so
they're running simulations right now
and Google has been running simulations
for a long time but I think it's a
combination of both right when I'm when
I talked about open Ai and the Rubik's
Cube
um they the hardest part was
transforming like getting the software
and then getting that to the hardware
right and and I think both parts are
really really important
for Tesla they have both parts they have
a million cars running in the road and
they also have the simulation where they
can see scenarios that you know they
they haven't
experienced before and they can actually
experience that you know in a simulated
environment so they can train a thousand
years in you know a few months and when
we think of this how long will it take
for Tesla to have fully self-driving
cars where I can sit in the back seat I
don't need to be anywhere near the
driver's seat and it'll drive me around
and that will be not only possible like
it can actually get me there but it will
be safe and that will become the norm do
you think yeah
um so we are in September of 2022
um I think it's gonna be either end of
this year or next year uh do you think
by the end of this year potentially in
three or four months we will have the
ability for the car to navigate uh the
everyday driving for anyone who wants to
sit in the test exactly
um but they're not gonna allow people to
do to do that so there is a technical
capability maybe there but their
regulatory approvals or or the uh uh
approval to actually do this on the
street won't happen as exactly an Elon
Musk has been saying that for years
right he has been saying oh we're gonna
have self-driving cars that are better
than humans by end of this year and he
has been saying that for five or six
years but the difference now is that
they have these simulator environments
that make the car know how to drive in
all these different scenarios right is
the simulations trying to uh get reps
because the computer needs to see the
situation over and over and over and
over again uh or is it if the computer
sees a situation one time it remembers
it forever and it's more so about the
super super long tail of a kid runs out
in the uh road then a car backs into the
road then a bicycle goes into the road
and just has to see every single
situation it's the ladder okay so it
needs to see all different scenarios
that it hasn't experienced before right
and it needs to know what to do if he
hasn't seen and maybe it can take some
wrong decision right so you need to have
all these simulated situations so it can
know when that situation actually
happens is Tesla in these simulations
like are they making the wrong decision
and like hitting in you know fake
pedestrians or or like crashing into
fake cars and like that's part of the
learning process is somebody then sits
there and says like no wrong decision
the car should have done this instead
and it's almost like this like human
feedback loop that's correcting uh the
actual computer yeah
and they actually have that information
also from the cards running in the in
the real world if there's if there's
accidents obviously
shouldn't have gone that way or if
someone like if the car is turning right
and the person driving the car actually
takes the wheel and drives somewhere
else they can actually get that data and
send back to Tesla so they actually when
they are gathering that data they don't
send all the video feeds directly to
Tesla they send selected frames because
else you would be a lot of data there
there so if you're just driving down the
highway and Tesla car all the uh uh
cameras on it is collecting all this
data if there's almost like no outlier
situation Tesla as a computer has seen a
million times driving down the highway
with other cars around it or whatever
it's when somebody grabs the wheel and
jerks it one way or the other or Slams
on the brakes or or there's some sort of
external or outlier type event that's
when maybe they say hey we want to see
that and that may be a situation that we
haven't seen before exactly and the
interesting part of Tesla is that they
have the biggest neural network running
at scale in the world really yeah so if
you think about it right like Facebook
Google they're a big pre like pretty big
companies right and most of the neural
networks that are running are very very
simple so they are they're running
neural networks to look at an image and
see oh look there's a beer there there
is you know this thing in this image or
Google also has a bird which is a big
Network a big Transformer that actually
answers questions so like if you if you
search some terms at Google some of the
the the answers will come from a neural
network right
um
and this is a dumb question but like the
neural network a lot of people like
where does that live is that on like
Facebook servers or Google servers
somewhere is that something that's in
the cloud and it's like they're using uh
other services is like how do you think
about like the neural network where does
that actually live yeah they're mostly
running gpus okay and that's why Nvidia
has been doing so well in in the market
selling weapons to the uh to the war
exactly and
and why gpus because gpus are really
good at doing metrics multiplications
which these neural networks require so
neural networks they're interesting the
reason why we use neural networks at the
end of the day is that a neural network
is a circuit and if you like have enough
long neural network it can simulate a
computer so a neural network is
basically a computer and a neural
network can actually represent any kind
of function that you may like they are
really good at solving the problems that
we like
and the way we train them is learn
linearly compare you know to to the
amount of data that we feed them so like
they're really really good at solving
the problems that we give them and
that's why so the way I I've always
thought about is like you have a
computer yeah right and the neural
network is software that resides on on
Hardware somewhere we take these massive
data sets we feed them in do we tell the
computer what to look for or do we just
feed it the data and then later when
we're looking for the outputs we're
querying that data set plus the software
like how much prep work I guess goes
into cleaning and structuring the data
that we feed it and specifically telling
the uh the neural network learn image
recognition learn this and then later we
can query it because we gave it that
instruction yeah so there are different
ways of training these neural networks
um Google for example had this
breakthrough at some point where they
fed a lot of YouTube videos okay and the
computer learned what a cat is because
people
cats on the Internet is an important
thing to know yeah exactly
um but most of these systems the way
they work is that you actually feed like
both the data and what you want to see
out of this data so for example for uh
Dolly they fed them images and captions
right and a big part of this system this
is actually cleaning out a cleaning out
that data and that's what Tesla does so
well right got it like they figure out
what data and how to clean that data
really well
um and the best systems is still you
need to like actually figure out okay
this is a image and this is the caption
you need to you know tie them together
and if we go and kind of zoom out for a
second right we say okay these neural
Nets and all this is very kind of uh
technical it's very nuanced in the
larger conversation uh there is
artificial intelligence yeah there is
machine learning and then another term
that people may or may not have heard of
is Agi right kind of uh the general
intelligence walk me through what is the
difference between these three things
because a lot of times like when I see
pitches from companies or I'm talking to
someone everyone's like ai ai artificial
intelligence is going to change the
world right but there's some nuance and
difference between these three things so
describe a little bit as to how people
should think about it yeah artificial
intelligence engulfs everything so
artificially the high level uh
terminology exactly uh so artificial
intelligence are systems that are
intelligent so they can interact with
you and whatnot machine learning is when
when computers learn the features by
themselves so it it learns by itself uh
these features that were you know uh
interacting with the world uh and AGI is
basically when computers get better at
humans at every single task got it so
AGI is when you know a computer is
better than humans that go at chess at
driving uh talking everything thinking
dreaming sleeping whatever
um so is it fair to say uh there is no
true AGI yet yeah is that that's kind of
a fair characterization but uh that is
something that people aspire to create
uh and if and when we get there that
would be a massive uh technical
breakthrough in in terms of computer
science yeah so one of the interesting
things is that when computers get to AGI
right there they will be better than
humans at every single task and we
created these computers so when they get
better than us they probably can create
computers that are better than they are
right so you have this exponential curve
that you hit when computers get to AGI
they can actually get better and better
over time should we be scared of that
like that sounds like pretty [ __ ]
crazy stuff right like if we can create
computers that are smarter than us in
every Dimension not just in kind of
mathematical computation but literally
it can drive better than us they can
play games better than us it can act
like a human better than us uh and then
those computers can create even smarter
computers and there's this exponential
runaway of of uh kind of artificial
intelligence
humans very quickly become the lowest on
the totem pole it seems yeah
I think we shouldn't worry about it even
though yeah even though
uh people talk about it and they hype it
up yep we are the ones creating these
tools and we can control it very well
I think when and if we hit that point
uh we we should cross that bridge when
we hit it right uh right now we have
many other problems to worry about like
their energy problems you know in in
Europe in California and you know other
areas of the country
um are there things that we could do now
to set ourselves up better for that
scenario or is it just something like
right now can everyone's talking and and
they're worried but actually there's
nothing that we could do in the moment
to change when we get to that situation
yeah so they're they're organizations
that are actually working on that so
there's an organization that came out of
like a bunch of people left open AI to
create this organization colon Tropic
where they're trying to prevent risks
that AI eventually can cause right
um but except that I don't think there's
much we can do right like it's it's
difficult to create policies about a
scenario that can happen yeah it's
really really hard okay now machine
learning yeah is here it exists we
talked about these like neural Nets is
machine learning similar or different in
terms of feeding it information and what
it does with that information to be able
to uh be useful to humans yeah machine
learning encompasses a lot of other
techniques neural networks are just one
like one subfield of machine learning
right and neural networks is
is basically a technique to simulate how
our brain works basically and neural
networks have been doing well so uh and
have been solving problems that we like
most of the new machine learning
techniques that we see today uh they are
using neural networks because they
perform really really well and I think
that's going to be the case in the
future are there other what are the
other types of machine learning
techniques yeah there there's
for example svms they're like what is
that like neuralness we've talked about
what is the svms how do they work uh
you're you're basically grabbing a lot
of data and and you know uh figuring out
where this data is in in a graph and
creating a line that divides you know uh
some of the points to to other points
it's basically you know um it sounds
like you're mapping connections between
different pieces of information and also
knowing where it is identified in in the
graph exactly exactly and then you have
like is it the wet this like I'm gonna
be really dumb I already told him that
uh all the questions I asked today
is so stupid
um but is that similar like what a web
crawler does no it's a little bit
different uh a web crawler usually uses
awesome matrix multiplication so uh at
least I got that part right
uh a web crawler usually you know
figures out how many links to a page
there are and and and you can determine
the importance of a page if there are a
lot of links to that page
um and then you can like yeah that's
basically it got it and so when we think
of machine learning there's uh neural
Nets there's svms there's a couple of
these different things but neural Nets
seem to be right now at least the
superior way to do machine learning and
that's why we're seeing so many people
go and use these in these various
applications exactly and and again the
reason for that is that they can
simulate computers really well and they
solve the kind of problems that we see
in the world really well and somehow
we're basically simulating how our brain
works right and somehow we develop this
thing this machine that
interacts really well with the world so
it's not a coincidence that you know
neural networks and our brains developed
so I think of humans of like the the uh
kind of physical world uh pre uh what we
think of a software today uh humans Rose
and dominance and we're like the King
Kongs of nature right like we can uh
collaborate we can think we can dream we
can uh uh organize resources in a very
unique way and for all intents and
purposes we have weaponry and like we
are the the dominators of uh of nature
on a global scale computers used to be
really dumb like there's punch cars like
you started out real low with the
computers but they have rapidly been
rising in uh efficiency efficacy uh
computing power all these different
things
as we get closer to that being an even
playing field between humans and
computers it then brings up this idea of
the Turing test which tests for uh is
the computer sentient is it not talk a
little bit about what is this Turing
test how did it come to be and how
effective is it yeah the Turing test was
developed by Turing which was a computer
scientist that developed this game
called the imitation game where you had
in one side of the i o you had a human
and then you had a black box and then
you had a human on one side then a
computer so the human would type
questions uh to both the uh both the
computer and the human and if the human
was fooled thinking that the machine was
a human or vice versa right uh the the
machine would pass What's called the
touring test got it so I'm sit here I'm
typing into a chat box yeah and uh on
one side there's a human on the other
side there's a computer if I can't tell
that the computer is the computer then
technically what's the difference so
that would be passing the Turing test
and then we could claim that the
computer was equivalent to the human
yeah this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep good sleep is a game changer
and the eight sleep pod is the best
sleep machine I sleep on it every single
night a great night of sleep allows you
to be healthier be more arrested and
have more energy throughout the day and
on the brand new eight sleep pod 3 you
can sleep as cold as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eatsleep.com pump not only do I sleep on
it every night it literally changed my
life and I begged the founders to let me
invest in the company eightsleep.com go
get yourself an eight sleep pod and get
a better night of sleep and the funny
thing is that since 2014 we've been
passing the touring test oh [ __ ]
and this is why the Google engineer got
fooled yes I thought that oh wait a
minute I'm talking to a sentient thing
holy [ __ ] I gotta like raise my hand and
and caution people yeah exactly if a
Google engineer was fooled by a chatbot
imagine you know the average human uh
and the funny thing is that humans are
fooled by computers much more when they
talk about sex interesting yeah and
especially males because males are dumb
um and so that's one of the ways that
people actually are able to fool humans
is they get males talking about sex to
computers and the computers trick the
men yeah
like if the machines get so smart that
they realize all we have to do is talk
about sex to men and then they're going
to do whatever we want that is a bad
scenario to go towards exactly and so
we've passed the touring tests and we're
being passed so almost eight years now
yeah exactly
um so we have been developing new tests
and you'll you know benchmarks and
computers have been doing better and
better so like for example DOTA write
the Game computers play better than
humans Starcraft which is really really
hard or goal
um computers pass humans there poker and
we've been doing better and better at
the exponential rate so driving driving
is another task that humans do right and
it's a game to some degree exactly it's
kind of a test right of like hey can we
figure out this technical breakthrough
to actually be able to do this yeah you
and I don't think about that when we're
in the car and like yo Elon make sure I
don't crash right but to some degree
like that is how the computer looks at
it is you can play the game of chess
with all the different possibilities and
rules and then you also could drive down
the street there's there's differences
but not nearly as many differences maybe
people think yeah I'm very optimistic in
in the way I think you know in the world
10 15 years or 50 years
um
from now and I actually think these
computers are just increasing our
productivity right so uh one example of
that is that you look at elevators
before elevators you had a human
actually moving the elevator around and
then we could automate that and then you
don't need humans anymore to you know uh
operate these elevators and the same
thing is happening in different areas
right so you look at
farming for example 100 years ago I
think 50 percent of their population was
working farming and now you have one
percent of the population a lot of
people drive trucks right now it's like
the most popular
uh job right now in the US is driving
trucks eventually you won't need to
drive trucks
and then you develop new jobs right so
talking in a podcast is a pretty new
like pretty new job quote and cult right
investing is a pretty new uh new job so
if you look at the percentage of GDP
um that the uis
if you look at the percentage of GDP
that entertainment has uh it has been
increasing over time in the US it was
six percent in the 1960s and it's now 10
percent wow so we're spending more and
more dollars in entertainment and as you
have more dollars you spend more in
leisure travel entertainment right and
that's what has been happening so as we
develop these tools we increase our
productivity which leaves us to do like
more fun things as a society right so
one of the things that's interesting to
me is uh if you go back to 1870 or so uh
about 75 percent of jobs were
characterized as uh uh kind of uh not
fun not uh exciting uh pretty tough life
um you know it's farming and that type
of stuff uh by what's called 1970 or so
we're down about 25 so pretty big
reduction in uh jobs that were uh uh not
necessarily aspirin rational there were
tough life type jobs
now if you fast forward to today you
already mentioned a couple of these jobs
that they're getting automated away or
it's easy to see truck driving is one
there'd be many others
how many of the jobs that we see in
today's society are not going to be done
by humans a hundred years from now like
when I think of Tesla's manufacturing
facility it doesn't look like uh you
know kind of a a manufacturing line
where people are putting on the car
doors and stuff like sure there are
humans there but it sure looks like
there's a hell of a lot of robots in
there if you look in Amazon's Warehouse
there's robots moving things around and
there's tape on the floor and you sort
of see like okay but then also if you go
and you look at white collar jobs like
it seems like software's coming for that
as well and so it doesn't feel like
there's really that many areas that are
safe from kind of the Automation and and
artificial intelligence that's coming is
that fair yeah and they never been safe
um so I think a hundred years from now
everyone is going to be a tick tock
dancer
I'm joking but like we're gonna change
the way we work and we we always change
the way we work right so in the
northeast of the US
there a lot of people who used to work
in manufacturing right and now they work
in service jobs so like work wise we've
been changing a lot throughout history
but if you actually look at productivity
we've been changing less and less over
time and that's one of the things that
Peter till talks a lot about right so
one of the things that has been
happening in the U.S is that we didn't
actually increase productivity so much
but we Outsource jobs so if you look at
Detroit right Detroit was the
manufacturing place here in the US and
we actually outsourced that to other
other parts of the world so like to
China and Mexico so a lot of the jobs
went away here in the US because of
globalization and not because of
automation automation is actually not
changing that much uh the economic pie
of the US but it will change a lot of
the job will be displaced but that's the
way it works right you a hundred years
ago most people would be Farmers maybe
you know maybe 200 years ago and most
people are not Farmers today I think
it's a good thing I think it's a good
thing that people you know are creative
they are like spending their dollars in
entertainment and Leisure and I think
we're gonna be in a much better place
100 years from now this is one of the
arguments uh of
um I think techno optimists if you will
right it's like hey we freed everyone up
from the farm Fields so they could go do
other things it's not like jobs
disappeared and now everyone is jobless
just new types of jobs showed up and
obviously we still have food for now uh
in terms of being able to feed the
global population yes there are areas
that struggle but uh we still get Farm
productivity even though maybe we don't
have as big of a portion of population
working in the fields now with that said
uh one of the areas that everyone has
always thought would be safe was the
creative jobs so for example uh what is
the hardest thing for a computer to do
everyone was like oh like you could be
an artist you could be a musician you
could do this stuff like that's going to
be really really hard for the computers
to ever compete with well fast forward
to today like not so fast uh the
machines sure as hell look like pretty
good artists right with all of this kind
of computer generated art or generative
art like did we get it wrong as a as
like human commenters on the state of
automation where like maybe some of
those creative jobs aren't nearly as
protected as we thought yeah so there's
this interesting quote so that says like
a human asks a robot can a robot write a
symphony can a robot turn a canvas into
a masterpiece and the the answer was no
but can you right you're not Mozart
you're not Picasso but now yes the
robots can can write a symphony they can
create a masterpiece
um
there was recent recently there was a
state fair where a human created a piece
of AI art using one of these systems
safe mode diffusion and actually won the
challenge right so AI was able to create
a masterpiece right now that brought
controversy yes exactly but it like it's
just increasing productivity right like
instead of humans creating every
thumbnail of a YouTube like video you
have a computer doing that but humans
still play a role because humans will
choose which thumbnail to put into an
image right
um and but if we go back to the art for
a second because I think it's an
important uh uh uh conversation that's
happening right now is this artist used
AI to create a generative uh piece of
art it could not be told if you looked
at you couldn't tell the difference
between oh that was Ai and that was a
human that created it and so it went
into a competition it won it was
selected as the best piece of art
the artist community at absolutely
freaked out they were like what are you
talking about this is cheating right
it's the equivalent of taking steroids
or performance enhancing drugs right for
athletes like this was the equivalent in
the art world uh and they were going
absolutely crazy
on the same side the artist uh the uh
engineer I'll call them uh to separate
from the artist
um and others were like well hold on a
second you're using tools to create your
art uh you are using uh paint brushes or
whatever other tools you're using like
we're using tools also it just so
happens that our tools are superior to
yours and so uh what's the big deal
that debate is not settled yet and it
feels like we go one or two paths either
people say like hey Art is Art and like
whoever can enter it into competitions
can do that uh or the second path is
like somehow there's a bifurcation
either the generative art is not allowed
to be entered or there's like a
generative art Division and then there's
like a human art division or something
like that like how does this play out
yeah so if you allow
um
if you allow people to take hormones and
steroids they will take it right so so
like if you look at people uh driving uh
bicycles right like riding bicycles
if they can take
steroids they will take it and they will
do whatever it takes to take steroids
right the same will probably be true for
the creative
creative type right
machines will help and make humans so
much more productive that
everyone will
try to use these tools right
and one interesting thing that I think
one interesting Trend that I think we'll
see in the next 10 years is that right
now most of like the internet allow
distribution to go down to zero and if
you look at Tick Tock Instagram YouTube
a lot of the engine that drives
recommendation is done by Machine
learning is done by computers that
select the next image video that you you
are gonna see right and they're much
better than humans at selecting you know
what you like to see
when when you do that though
Canon machine pick what will win or is
it the machine says here's 10 options
and the human says that's the one that's
gonna win
both can work right okay so humans still
can choose whatever you know like you
can still have humans and pick but
machines will probably be better at some
point yeah maybe even today yeah so like
if you look at YouTube's uh
recommendation algorithm or even if you
look at tick tock's recommendation
algorithm is really really really good
at selecting what video people like to
see
and and I would argue it's better than
humans at selecting videos you know that
people would like 100 agree
and
we're seeing recommendation algorithms
today right but we're gonna see
like
generated art and videos 10 years from
now so most of the media that we consume
today is generated by humans right
movies images and whatnot I imagine 10
years from now most of the video most of
the media that we consume is gonna be
created by computers you still have a
human
determining look I have this script
please generate that right
but a lot of the media that will
consumer will be generated by computers
I went down a rabbit hole uh I don't
know six to eight weeks ago
uh and there's a a gentleman uh who I
found online
um and uh not in a weird way but just
like on Twitter and he was tweeting
about uh generative art and all this
stuff and uh he had created a Sci-Fi
um uh mini series essentially called
salt s-a-l-t and in this uh Sci-Fi
series my understanding is that he was
able to generate not just the imagery
but also the video using uh uh kind of
these generative machines the AI uh
whatever he provided his own voice so he
did the voiceover but what he was
building was this idea of a pick your
own adventure movie yeah and so his idea
was like okay normally for us to go
ahead
sit down uh and create an entire set get
the actors and do all this stuff
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
millions of dollars in budget to be able
to make a movie an actual real movie
but if I can sit here with my computer
on a Saturday essentially and do
something that looks pretty good you
know close to it in quality uh that's
gonna have a profound impact now
what he then said was if you drop the
cost of creating this imagery and and
kind of this movie
you then can replicate many different
scenarios so rather than watch Top Gun
and every single person who watches Top
Gun gets the same outcome what happens
when all of a sudden now you go left and
pick option one I pick option two and
our friend picks option three and you
have these kind of uh multi uh uh kind
of paths to choose but that's a whole
world that it seems like the content you
know system or industry is not set up to
do
but you can also see some creative
people saying wait a minute there's a
lot of things we can do now that
previously weren't possible because of
this technology yeah absolutely and so
if you actually look at games games are
bigger in size than movies they're much
much much bigger and the reason why is
because people can interact and they can
decide what to do next and generative
art generative media is gonna be more
important to games than movies right
because you can create these characters
that have their own lives you can create
all these different scenarios all that
long tail that we talked about before
can be created for games and games will
be much more interesting in the future
because of AI yeah there's another uh
startup called osmosis studio and what
they do is they use uh these same
generative machines and they can do
product photo shoots without actually
having to do the actual photos so a lot
of people don't know but these companies
will spend tens of thousands sometimes
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
literally get two or three models to
show up they bring their equipment they
do the whole setup they have to hire uh
the the photographers or uh uh um uh the
videographers or whoever and they go
ahead and they do the photo shoot and
that sounds insane because it takes a
whole day or whatever and it costs you
know a ton of money now what they're
basically saying is you could just sit
there and say like
I need uh an African-American woman uh
with a uh Brooklyn Street background uh
sitting on a bicycle in the Forefront
holding you know product X and then it
takes a second and Bam there you go
there's the image and now you can go use
that as a product placement imagery on
your website or or whatever but you
didn't have to go find the location hire
the photographer get the model bring
your product all the stuff
and when I saw it I was like holy [ __ ]
like these machines are going to
decimate Industries yeah they'll create
new companies that will be very very
efficient right
um
and like the next picture the next epic
epic games will be created by Machine
learning algorithms right I think so yes
100 like Pixar right now is not a very
efficient company and you have very
creative people that have amazing ideas
but it's really hard for them to
translate these ideas to an actual
product right with these algorithms you
can actually create a script you can
have your idea
you can actually go from an idea to
product much faster and so if you look
at it you're just increasing
productivity if you actually look at
different Industries you're going from
institutions to individuals right and
that's the same thing that's going to
happen to games that's the same thing
that's gonna happen to movies and you
like if you look at you know media Joe
Rogan Russell Brand they're bigger than
CNN Fox News of course uh investors you
have like individual investors they're
bigger than than VC companies so you
have you have a lot queue you have Josh
Buckley they're bigger than Benchmark
for example if you have e-commerce you
have Kylie Jenner right you have Tom
Brady you have e or like Kanye West uh
they're bigger you know than than other
brands right
the same thing is gonna happen to games
the same thing is going to happen to
movies right so you think the individual
uh creators will actually end up being
bigger and a lot of it is because
they're going to have these tools that
will give them way more leverage to
create this stuff than even a Pixar or
whoever exactly exactly right and you
see that in technology overall right if
you look at the best companies they
didn't have that many people so if you
look at whatsapp Instagram they had 20
people or 14 people when they had
significant scale right you see unicorns
with 10 20 people I think 10 years from
now it could be the case that you see
unicorns with one person right so you
think that we will potentially we will
have billion dollar companies created
with only one employee absolutely
that is wild
I mean like if you look at crypto right
yep
Bitcoin it was a I mean you had a set of
people but the initial idea was created
by one individual probably Satoshi
Nakamoto who I think was Elon Musk but
yeah you think Elon Musk is Satoshi yeah
no come on yeah yeah uh wait hold on why
do you think that Elon Musk is Satoshi
um there are a bunch of clues why he's
Satoshi Nakamoto so for example the code
base uh was like is written in C plus
plus which is this programming language
and it's basically a block uh and that
that's usually how Elon Elon programs is
tough also the way uh he he used to type
his sentences in in this uh Forum uh
there were like double spaces between
you know one sentence and another that's
how Elon Musk writes uh the way he talks
Satoshi Nakamoto writes in the Forum he
talks about you know uh born guys in the
Forum and then you have pedo guys you
know there are a bunch of clues that
point out to the fact that you know Elon
Musk uh is Satoshi Nakamoto he has been
thinking about money for you know a long
long time PayPal the original idea was
to create like money to the world to
replace you know
these Banks and so hold on a second
I disagree with you that Elon is Satoshi
but let's go down this path and say yeah
uh if Elon was Satoshi yeah
would they just put them in jail like
would it just be like they just like man
we got to stop this guy that's why he
can't say his Satoshi Nakamoto right you
think so yeah like for the longest time
I thought okay Elon Musk is gonna be the
richest man alive and then it's gonna be
Satoshi Nakamoto right because people
would have an absolute meltdown if it
came out that Elon was Satoshi but both
good meltdown and bad milk yeah yeah
there's people in the Bitcoin Community
who would not be super ecstatic about it
there's people outside the Bitcoin
Community who would uh be ecstatic about
like it would just be mass chaos I know
uh and I I think he will never say that
his Satoshi Nakamoto I don't think he
has to self discipline from looking from
the outside I think that somebody would
say something stupid to him and he would
just he's underrated I think people
don't realize how smart he is
um one of the things like he he
talks a lot of [ __ ] in Twitter because
that drives engagement yes he knows that
that drives engagement that's why he's
so funny on Twitter right like creating
SpaceX like it's amazing he created
rockets that lend themselves in their
own fit right he's he's creating
self-driving cars
this guy is nuts this guy is complaining
not
people like underrate him he's like he's
Steve Jobs on steroids yep
um
anyway
Satoshi Nakamoto has a really strong
incentive to take all his coins because
he's gonna be the richest man alive or
woman or whatever
Elon Musk is already the richest man
alive right he doesn't think he wouldn't
touch the coins because he doesn't need
him yeah exactly if it was some random
guy right he has a strong incentive to
take out the coins but if you already
the richest man alive
like taking out the coins you're you're
still gonna be the richest man in life
so it doesn't matter
all right let's put that to the side for
a second when you think of uh uh kind of
what is actually happening though with a
lot of these Technologies uh it is very
obvious that we're going to drastically
Drive the cost of creating some of these
products to zero uh or our Trend towards
zero uh it will also unleash immense
disruption in some of these industries
what are the areas where you think that
we could apply artificial intelligence
machine learning even eventually AGI
most uh um kind of uh quickly but also
have the largest impact on society or
creating economic value what's ripe for
disruption everything
but like if you had to pick one or two
industries what would you pick I mean
the first one is going to be media like
that's the first industry that's gonna
be displaced and right now we're seeing
technology being displaced by remote
right so we're seeing Silicon Valley
basically Dismantling in front of our
eyes and the same thing that's happening
to San Francisco is and Silicon Valley
happened to Detroit because of
globalization right in the 50s Detroit
was the SEC
in the 50s Detroit was the richest city
in the world by income
Kata and now is the second poorest big
city so it's the first income per capita
in the country yeah and now it's the
second worst yeah Jesus talk about
volatility
I think the same thing is happening to
Silicon Valley right now there's a big
migration because of remote work and the
same thing is going to happen to
Hollywood right if you look at the
biggest stars in media right now they're
not in L.A right Mr Beast
yeah exactly Logan Paul was in LA he now
moved to Puerto Rico he's all over the
place but the biggest stars in YouTube
and elsewhere they're moving away
because they don't need to be in
Hollywood right I I was wondering the
other day
um could you name an actor or actress
that comes from the traditional movie
world that's under the age of 25.
28 something like that
I couldn't yeah now
I've never been into Hollywood and kind
of entertainment scene and all that
stuff uh but I know who Mr Beast is yeah
I know who Jake and Logan Paul are right
I know who uh a number of The Tick Tock
stars are right like all of these other
platforms I know who they are I know the
people on Twitter I know Casey nestat
right like I know all of these
individuals who have built massive
online followings
I don't think I could name a uh a pure
actor or actress now there's an argument
that like many of the people who have
starred in some of these movies that are
on the younger side uh they built their
career somewhere else and they cross
over so I think of
um was the movie A Star is Born right
with uh Lady Gaga I think yeah this
person in there
um like that's a musician that crosses
over and so when you start to to see
this it's like
either one you've got to be uh
multifaceted and kind of in different
Industries or you actually have to go to
where the attention is yeah like the
attention is not in the Hollywood studio
model yeah the smartest people figure
out that they don't need to be in
Hollywood so you look at Joe Rogan you
look at Mr Beast they're all outside of
Hollywood and they distribute through
the internet right so that's that's a
big Trend that we're gonna see right
like we're gonna see Hollywood Studios
outside of Hollywood the next Disney is
not gonna be created you know in
Hollywood it's gonna be created outside
uh of Hollywood but I still think the
West is gonna win like I still think
America is gonna be you know the biggest
country in the world like a lot of
people talk about Asia right but if you
look at the biggest companies the most
Innovative companies they're still in
the US SpaceX Tesla you look at Apple
you look at you know Zoom they are all
in the US and they're gonna still be in
the west yeah but they're gonna be
distributed as we talk about Hollywood
and AI disrupting it in this generative
media uh you have a very interesting
background you uh were at Genesis group
at MIT yeah uh and I have to admit I
didn't know that much about uh Genesis
group but uh I went and I was looking it
up and uh reading a little bit and then
I opened a second Tab and a third they
have like 10 tabs open now in the
browser right like holy [ __ ] this is
cool stuff so talk a little bit about
what exactly is the body of work that
Genesis group at MIT is working on yeah
um so the group was basically working in
trying to simulate the human mind into a
computer
a small task and a lot of it involved
studying how the human brain works so
that's why I have a Fascination about
the human brain and then I I talk a lot
about it in my book
um about how the human brain works so we
have to understand if we're going to try
to recreate human intelligence we have
to understand the thing the brain where
the intelligence lives in order to then
understand how we can recreate it
exactly okay and and at the end of the
day I think with neural networks we can
do that right uh neural networks they're
basically created based on our neurons
and that's a very
it's the most basic part of our brain
right
um and and the reason why I think with
neural networks we will be able to to
simulate brains is because you like
that's that's the only thing that we
need uh I I'm thinking sorry um
so if you look at planes for example
right we understand the physics of you
know how how air flows and whatnot we
don't need to assimilate how exactly how
a bird looks uh to fly and I think the
same thing applies to computers we don't
need to exactly know how each part of
the brain interacts with each other it
would be nice right but we understand
the physics how each neuron works and a
neural network is basically a network of
how this simple
parts of our brain interact and because
of that I think that will eventually you
know get to AGI and so Genesis group is
looking at how do we recreate the human
brain with computers
um study the brain makes sense then
what's kind of the next step in in doing
this or what is the body of work that
they're focused on right now yeah so so
they're basically trying to replicate
the human brain and so you have like
different parts of it you have attention
you have you know uh uh our motor system
works our new neuron uh
um sorry sorry our neocortex works and
how they interact with each other so
they're trying to simulate these
different parts of the brain right and
when I think of the brain I think of
literally the brain but obviously my
ability to see is using my brain plus my
eyeballs uh to synthesize what what
actually uh my eyes are seeing how much
of the work to recreate these
software-based systems takes into
account things that interact with the
brain like the eyes or even the ears or
whatever versus no we're just trying to
understand how the brain itself works
and so once the information is put into
the brain that's really what we're
focused on yeah so one of the
interesting Parts about the vision is
that most of the data that's actually
being transported is from our brain to
our eyes like I think 80 percent of you
can actually see the synapses and see
how much of the data is sent from your
eyes to your brain and most of the data
is actually sent from our brain to our
eyes
and that's crazy yeah and we don't
understand why is that right uh if you
actually look at for example our gut
bacteria the way our bacteria interact
with our body can interfere how how we
feel that day so we don't understand
humans that well right
um and so a big part of what Genesis was
trying to do is trying to understand why
for example 80 percent of the data is
sent from the brain to our eyes we don't
understand that right
in my personal view you don't
necessarily need to understand that to
actually
recreate systems that do better than
humans at different tasks but it would
be nice to understand how our brain and
body interact with the world yeah and it
feels like these machines are only going
to get better over time but what about
the engineers behind the machines so
when I think of uh these neural Nets or
I think of any of the artificial
intelligence machine learning stuff like
let's put my uh um my knowledge at
novice level right
I have to guess the engineers who are
working on this stuff today 20 years ago
had knew nothing about it right there's
some Gap where we went from hey very few
Engineers know anything about this or
are focused on this to now uh there's a
bigger percentage but the percentage
probably is pretty small of the overall
engineer population in you know the
United States or globally
do we eventually have every engineer as
an AI engineer because it's just another
tool in their toolbox of computer
science to be able to actually do the
things they want to do exactly yeah so
we like we create new tools and people
we spread these tools really fast so
like for example gpt3 or stable
diffusion we create a neural network and
everyone can use that neural network you
just need to create once right stable
diffusion what they did is that they
learned how Dal Lee which is this
computer software that takes text and
creates images they learn how they did
it and they just replicate it and they
distribute this toolbox to everyone
so that's what's happening how much does
it cost to do that today's episode is
brought to you by ftxus they're a safe
regulated way to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they've got very cheap
fees sometimes as much as 85 percent
cheaper than their competitors there's
also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately FTX us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code Pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today like to
create Dolly stable diffusion or even
gbt3 like how much money is being spent
to create a neural network so it depends
on the neural network so gpt3 costs
around seven million dollars a
apparently I don't know if that is a lot
or a little compared to what I would
have expected yeah and like it's a lot
seven Millions a lot but also to create
something gpt3 I you would think maybe
they have spent tens of millions of
dollars
um stable diffusion costs around 600 uh
thousand dollars really yeah so it's not
that much and I think the reason for
that is because you need you have a set
of gpus so you usually so for stable
diffusion I think they use 256 gpus and
they need to train for a certain period
of time and and
the longer you train it the better it
gets but but people get tired after some
points so you usually train these
networks for a month or around a month
you know before you actually see in the
real world and I think that creates a
constraint
um also like these are research Labs
right open AI uh it's probably
generating a little bit of money because
they're selling you know access to their
API but they're not Tesla they're not
like they're not Google or they're not
meta so they can't spend a billion
dollars in these neural networks
um it's funny though because we've been
increasing exponentially the size of
these neural networks the size of you
know these machines and that trend is
going to continue right so
to create one of these uh neural Nets
right let's say that uh I wanted to
create stable diffusion yeah
um
I put six hundred thousand dollars aside
do I need one engineer do I need 50
Engineers like how big is the team to
build something like that and then what
are the steps of what they're actually
going to do yeah I've done that before
not stable diffusion but I've I got
taxed and created like recreated Obama's
voice okay uh with a neural network so
so you took tax yeah from like a speech
or something yeah exactly so I got a
bunch of uh of data from you know
Obama's speech and then you have the
text and then you have the audio and
then you have a lot of data so you have
hours and hours of text and audio and
then you have this neural network that
you know you're gonna train on this data
and you train for you know uh two weeks
three weeks a month in a bunch of gpus
and how much does that cost let's say a
month yeah so it depends how many gpus
you use so like eight gpus for a month
maybe it's like 5K 10K okay
um so it depends on you know how much
money you're willing to spend right and
then you had Obama's voice yeah and you
could basically have his voice say
anything because of the quality yeah
it's not great the the the like
the neural network that are training
like didn't exactly uh recreate his
voice because I didn't spend as much
money but you can get one person to do
it right uh and how long uh would it
have taken for you to get it good uh it
depends if I use if I use more gpus for
two weeks maybe I would get it better
right so let's say if you spent fifty
thousand dollars maybe a 100K or 500k
would get better but like
these systems are getting better because
the amount of compute that we can use is
getting cheaper and cheaper so every
year Nvidia releases a new GPU that's
more powerful and the old gpus get
cheaper and cheaper right so what it
costs you know today a million dollars
five years from now is gonna cost one or
ten dollars right that's crazy yeah that
is absolutely insane yeah and so when
you think of this uh let's say that you
had successfully uh recreated Obama's
voice now he's a little bit difficult
for president and all stuff but uh if
you were able to recreate that what are
the things that you would do with it in
this world that we're heading into
I mean you can create any media right
you can create any video you can create
any voice and I think one of the
important things that we will need to do
is to creep cryptographically sign real
media so whenever we record with our
iPhones your iPhone will probably need
to verify that this is real media like
real because like it's not real
necessarily because they also do much
like authentic almost yeah exactly
because they have also machine learning
algorithms to actually improve the image
right like everything has machine
learning better than it but they're
probably cryptographically sign verify
that this is authentic because at some
point we'll get machines that produce
media that's completely
indistinguishable from real media
um and when you think about something
like this it feels like
right now we have a decent understanding
of where we are from a technical
standpoint but the possibilities of how
people will apply this we're just the
tip of the iceberg yeah right it is
still got quite a bit of Runway to go
um how can engineers get to the position
where they're able to actually train
these neural Nets so let's say
somebody's watching this and and let's
start with a person who already has some
technical background are they taking
like uh uh uh some sort of program
online and they watch some YouTube
videos and like they're ready to rock
and roll are they having to go to like
some sort of class uh how hard is it for
them to go from I'm just kind of a quote
regular engineer to okay now I'm armed
with you know the weapons of information
Warfare in the 21st century uh read my
book yeah
um but a lot of the information is
available online uh so
um
you can actually find a lot of the
information online so for example
Android cup party was head of Tesla AI
for example he's releasing videos of how
to train some different neural networks
right uh so you can find a lot of that
information online like everything right
like if you want to be the best at
something you can probably find
everything online right yeah and what
about people who have no uh technical
expertise whatsoever I know that you're
I think an investor in replit yeah uh I
am as well and they've blown me away
with taking nothing to you have some
technical knowledge but is that the path
that most non-technical people are going
or are they doing other things yeah
um
so I I think for most people
um you're not necessarily going to train
these neural networks for computer
scientists I think most people will also
not train these neural networks because
you just create once and then you
replicate right I don't need to recreate
stable diffusion to use it right
um and these neural networks are also
helping computer scientists write better
software so open AI with GitHub they
release a tool that actually completes
your code so you can type it out oh like
you know can you write this code for me
the machine learning algorithm will
actually write it's not perfect so it's
still it's like assisting software
developers right so this these machines
will help software developers be more
productive how many companies outside of
like Tesla are using some sort of AI or
machine learning is it every company
every company every tech company needs
to use AI nowadays so if you think about
Apple right they use machine learning to
improve your images if you think about
Spotify they recommend music for you if
you think about Facebook Newsfeed has AI
if you think about Open Door they're
like they're predicting the price to buy
your your products every tech company is
becoming an AI company so talk about
open doors a good example I think people
understand the idea of recommending
music or the news feed and the ranking
algorithm but something like open door
which uh in a very general sense for
this they don't know uh you want to sell
your house you don't want to wait to
find the buyer uh and so you can go to
Open Door I think it's within 24 or 72
hours whatever they will give you a
price that they're willing to buy now
and I think they do it in cash uh and
basically you're done move on they'll
hold the house and they'll go try to
find a buyer at some point in the future
but where is some of this more advanced
technology coming in into play so to
determine the right price they are using
AI machine learning algorithm right
right so you take a bunch of images you
you enter all the information that open
door needs to determine the right price
so they they basically get a lot of
information of different houses and
their features and their price and based
on all that data they can actually
determine the price of a house so if I
ask Keith or boy how accurate is it
he'll say it's 100
which is why I love them but uh how do
you think about like accuracy and
especially in a complex Market where
housing the price today is not the price
three weeks ago or three months ago
versus three years ago like it does move
pretty quickly so how do you think about
accuracy yeah I think housing doesn't
move as quickly as people think uh if
you actually look at the 2008 uh crisis
right I think housing was moving at two
percent uh every month down two percent
uh housing is going down over time right
now because interest rates are going up
right so I think housing doesn't move as
as much I don't know how accurate you
need to be because
Open Door is giving you cash right now
right so you don't necessarily need to
give their exact offer you may give an
offer that's a bit lower right because
if you're willing to sell your house
really fast you might want you you might
sell for a cheaper price than you're
selling you know if you if it took you a
year or like a few months right so it
doesn't need to be exactly right but it
needs to be within you know some
reasonable uh bounce yeah it's
fascinating to understand how pervasive
this technology has gotten and how good
it gets especially not just in a general
oh AI is getting better but when one
company takes technology applies it and
then they begin to compound that
knowledge and that experience they're
getting the feedback of we bought this
house for X dollars we were able to sell
it for y dollars oh that's a certain
margin maybe we can actually offer lower
later oh no people won't actually sell
at that price let's bring it back up and
you just begin to get all these data
points to the point where it just
becomes really well machine yeah and
this feedback loop is really really
important right so you have companies
that focus in transcription there are
companies that focus on media there are
companies that focus on real estate
there are companies that Focus
music right so uh because they're
getting that feedback loop they get
better and better over time and there's
like a feedback loop and there's a will
uh that you know they they're getting
better and better and that's why I think
Tesla for example is gonna win uh with
self-driving cars there there will be
other companies that are gonna do really
well but they already have a million
cars out there so it's gonna take some
time for other companies to eventually
catch up to Tesla I'm not the smartest
guy when it comes to self-driving cars
and the uh the competition between
individual companies but I do feel like
every smart person I know is like yeah
Tesla is Miles Ahead than everyone else
uh which uh I'll take their word for it
right
um another company that I hear AI talked
about all the time uh usually a negative
uh sense but this still talked about is
Tick Tock yeah what is Tick Tock doing
with artificial intelligence yeah I mean
they're just predicting the next video
okay so similar to Facebook or Spotify
or whatever exactly I I think
I think Tick Tock has relevance but I I
think people overplay how much influence
they have right uh at the end of the day
people
used to say why is the TV like showing
so much dumb stuff right yeah it's
making us Dumber it's because people
want to see that right if you don't show
what people want to see people just
switch off right they they transition
out of a media channel and I I think
Tick Tock is the new MTV it's the new
media channel Instagram is the same
right uh and is Tick Tock better I'm
gonna put better in air quotes because
uh everyone's like oh it's so good at
recommending it's addictive it's all
these things is that because they're
actually collecting more data and so
more data gives them more accuracy
whereas if you were to take all of the
information that Instagram uh collects
and then all the information that Tick
Tock collects my understanding again
from two hours of Googling around uh a
few months ago is that Tick Tock
collects way more information and then
if you're using these uh kind of AI uh
um uh neural Nets you should end up
getting a more accurate predictive
engine than if you had less data yeah I
I think Facebook or Instagram is
collecting as much data that is needed
uh compared to tick tock it's just Tick
Tock was first at using this algorithmic
feed compared to your social feed uh I
think a year from now two years from now
uh Instagram will have
an algorithmic feed that as is as good
or better than Tick Tock right so in
some way I may go on Instagram and not
see a ton of content from my friends and
family or people I've chosen to follow I
could just see like viral videos yeah
and people want to see that it's funny
uh because you're
your stated preference is not your
reveal preference right you may say oh I
don't like that like it was funny I
think Kim Kardashian or uh Kris Jenner
was saying I don't like I would just
want to see my friends I don't want to
see this Instagram influencers but she's
an influencer herself like she wants
everyone to see her content exactly
um
people want to see algorithmic
feeds that's their reveal preference
even though they say they want to see
their friends right some people still
want to see their friends but you know
most people want to see this algorithm
make fits but in terms of data
I think the company that collects the
most data is Google right when you're
talking about Tick Tock you just told me
I googled this you're using your Chrome
browser probably uh to search for things
if you actually download the data that
you have on Google compared to Facebook
or anywhere else Google probably has the
most data compared to any other company
uh they can use that data some like
differently right but in terms of
comparing how much data each one
collects Google collects the most yeah
when you think of non-tech Industries
right yeah and Tech is kind of permeated
into a lot of these industries now uh so
maybe we go to more kind of blue color
type uh uh jobs or companies are there
obvious areas where somebody will build
artificial intelligence companies to
help the non-tech Industries or
companies yeah and it's happening
already you know uh every industry is
being helped by AI so if you think about
about real estate you have opened or
right if you think about lawyers there
there are companies that are trying to
predict
um
how
um how a case is Gonna Do Right
interesting uh what like which argument
you could make to increase exactly you
would win exactly and depending on the
judge right so every industry if you
look at medicine you have you know AR AI
algorithms predicting if you have skin
cancer or not you have you know uh AR
algorithms predicting how a protein is
going to look based on the genes right
and so like every industry is going to
be helped by Ai and
are there major risks to this so we
talked about the AGI risk of like hey
one day the machines get too big but in
the shorter term are there risks that
you've identified around the increased
use of AI that maybe people aren't
thinking about yeah I think the biggest
risk is around recommendation algorithms
um and and again when we talk about
censorship right uh if you look at
social media uh
social media companies are the most
powerful companies in the world and
that's why there's so much scrutiny
around Facebook because the most
powerful company before that was the New
York Times the New York Times Did
dictated what people thought right if
you think about the wmds in Iraq right
it was a false story but it determined
the future of the US right and right now
social media plays that role right so
when people talk about you know
misinformation or even these
recommendation algorithms they're
talking about power why there's so much
scrutiny around Facebook is because
there's a set of people that won't
control what other people see and so if
you look at you know the New York Post
story when there was censorship around
that story a lot of people didn't see
that story and that may have determined
you know
the election results and so
I think these like social media is the
and recommendation algorithms are like
the most important part of you know AI
that we see today yeah
um
but I think in the long run if if a
company decides what media you see and
uh and is not what people want to see
people migrate right if you look at you
know uh uh these markets they evolve
really fast people complain a lot about
Twitter but they still use Twitter I
think Twitter somehow is the digital uh
manifestation of San Francisco people
like you know don't like San Francisco
that much but there was a network effect
people used to live there and people are
moving away from there I think the same
things is happening with Twitter right
you're creating this social media
platforms outside of Twitter so I'm
investor in firecaster which you know is
a decentralized social network and
people are moving away from Twitter to
forecaster to other social media
platforms if you think about YouTube
there's Rumble there are other social
media platforms if Facebook doesn't
serve what people want they will just
move away yeah it makes complete sense I
mean think Dan Romero who's building
forecaster has thought a lot about what
does those networks look like what would
be something that people would be
willing to move away for one of the
things I've always said is I used to get
all these pictures all the time we're
gonna build decentralized Twitter I'm
like okay what's the difference like
it's Twitter but decentralized and I was
like nobody is going to care because
nobody actually is going to move just
for the decentralization that was a
better product if there's a certain
conversation or certain type of user
that they want to engage with and they
feel like it's a superior experience in
whatever way oh and it happens to be
decentralized sure maybe they'll be
interested but the idea that we're just
going to take every single thing and
copy it and then decentralize it it
feels like that is uh Elementary
thinking and not really where the the
world's going to go exactly you need
better products and that's the same
Insight that Elon Musk had with electric
cars right I'm gonna build electric cars
nobody cares nobody wants to drive a
Prius I mean some people want but yeah
uh but Teslas are the the best cars in
the market and they happen to be these
right and that's why people are buying
them yeah and that's the same thing for
you know decentralized networks you
can't only just create a decentralized
network nobody cares nobody cares you
need to create better products and
that's why people choose one product
over another but it takes time right
like Twitter there is a network effect
there but you know once you start moving
away from from there uh you eventually
lose that Network effect yeah that makes
uh that makes a lot of sense tell me
about Bitcoin in cryptocurrencies in
general like how do you view them
fitting into this whole world yeah I I
think Bitcoin is the biggest invention
uh after the internet I think will have
a bigger impact than the internet so
there's a lot of controversy around
social media because all these old
companies they lost power right like the
New York Times and all these other
networks like Fox News CNN and why not
they lost power and now the individuals
individuals have hour and so like they
have more information and whatnot and
all these old companies that held so
much power for so long they're screaming
ah like please stop stop stop but you
can't stop Tech you can't stop Evolution
right
the same thing is happening with Bitcoin
and all these cryptocurrencies you have
better money and and and they're private
why why was there so much fight over who
is going to be the next president
because they have the control of the
printing press they have the control of
the central bank so they can actually
print so much money and give to other
like different states right uh the US
has so much power because of the dollar
and the US is losing power because you
know other countries are moving away
from the dollar and that's what's gonna
happen with Bitcoin and our other
cryptocurrencies
you're moving from you know the state
controlling money to private like having
private money and that changes
everything
one of the biggest things that people
don't talk too much about is
decentralized finance right when you
look at interest rates in the US they're
really really low and that's why I think
there's so much craziness in big cities
right why why is real estate so
expensive in in big cities it's because
interest rates are really really low and
people can leverage up so so so much and
then real estate becomes really
expensive and then you have homelessness
you have people like not being able to
have their own families and create their
own families in these big cities and
that has been happening in the US and
you have some cities that have this
problem uh at the peak right and the
whole West is seeing that so like if you
look at the fear system the dollar and
Euro like European cities are starting
to have the same problem right when you
have interest rates they're not driven
by you know the state so right now what
happens you know is that this the
government issues that that at zero
percent interest rate now they're
increasing a little bit but they can't
increase too much because you know you
have the government and even private
companies over lever it over leverage
right and when you increase the interest
rates like they can't pay you know that
much debt and they can't borrow as much
right
um and with zero percent interest rates
here in the US Americans have a huge
Advantage compared to developing
countries so if you go to Brazil where
I'm from interest rates are much much
higher so the cost of capital in Brazil
is much higher but what's the difference
between the average Brazilian and the
average American
it's not that much right like they're
pretty similar uh and so why are
interest rates in Brazil so much higher
is because historically the government
in Brazil is pretty shitty right
compared to the government of the US
historically sometimes the U.S has uh it
goes back and forth but definitely I
think most people say it's more stable
it's more stable exactly and so that's
why interest rates are so low here but
is that also a thing where when
inflation hits globally us but also
everywhere else Brazilians know what
what's coming like Brazilians understand
inflation and they're like oh [ __ ] jack
up the interest rate to try to get ahead
of this thing whereas in the US maybe
we're a little bit behind the curve or
is that something that Americans are
saying without really understanding the
difference of the two countries yeah I
mean some countries understand interest
rates better than others uh Brazil is
doing much better than the us right now
economic economically and also in terms
of inflation there is less inflation in
Brazil right now than in the US crazy
yeah it's crazy to think about but it's
mismanagement
um but yeah like Brazilians in
understand inflation much better but
they also understand interest rates much
better when you have such high interest
rates your cost of money is much much
higher and I think that's much more
important than inflation inflation plays
a role but if you can borrow money for
much cheaper why wouldn't you right and
that's what crypto enables right when
you have Bitcoin when you have other
cryptocurrencies you can borrow and lend
money in a different like the interest
rates are much much different than you
know your state owned uh interest rates
right and that will drive a lot of
development and I think that will change
the the world like much more you know
like when you have Bitcoin and you can
borrow money at
much cheaper in the in Brazil uh that
will have profound effects and so you
and so you have areas in Brazil there
will be much much richer uh there will
be areas that won't be as Rich right but
the individual will have the choice of
having you know different uh who choose
their own money yeah that makes sense
um how do you see artificial
intelligence in Bitcoin playing with
each other are there things that people
will use AI around Bitcoin that are
obvious right now uh so
I I think uh I I think Naval had this
this quote that was pretty interesting I
think every person is going to be
investor in the future and now that
doesn't have to be exactly exactly they
will have to be and so when I think
about cryptocurrencies in general I
think you're you're investing in some
technology right and and and
cryptocurrencies they enable global
investment right in the past to invest
in in the US market you usually had to
be us-based right to invest in Apple to
invest in Microsoft you had to be us
based most people that I know in Brazil
they they didn't invest in Microsoft
they didn't invest in Apple but a lot of
people here in the US they invested in
the stack companies but right now when
we talk about cryptocurrencies when I go
back home everyone is talking about it
they are putting money into it it's a
goal mobile
uh
it's a global movement right AI just
increases productivity uh and so
uh when you look at it AI is just gonna
transition this world where everyone
becomes an investor yeah it's
fascinating when you think of on a
global scale and then also I guess the
only way that I could really see right
now where it's like already people are
trying this or at least I've seen uh
with Bitcoin specifically is you have a
little bit of artificial intelligence uh
that's being used by the energy
companies and the miners of when to
actually consume the power for Bitcoin
versus go ahead and return the uh power
back to the grid and then also I've seen
some people talking about like uh
routing liquidity and the lightning
Network and trying to understand what
the right path is what's the most cost
effective that type of stuff
um you've got maybe some trading stuff
that people are doing I'm less familiar
or intellectually interested in that
stuff but uh uh definitely people
looking at tons and tons of data trying
to understand what are the different
um uh kind of things that they can pull
out a signal and and go from there as
well right yeah so it's just increasing
productivity when you think about it if
it's mining if it's routing money right
AI usually you have a heuristic you have
a goal and you're trying to improve that
yeah and that's what it's doing right so
if you look at different Industries it's
always helping improve productivity yeah
that makes sense talk to me about uh the
book that you wrote so this book is
fascinating to me because uh it really
unpacks a lot of what I think is opaque
to people so to where did you get the
idea to write a book and what was that
process like to write this yeah so I
think AI is impacting every industry
right so if you're taking a photo with
your iPhone it's using a machine
learning algorithm to like predict
what's the best image right or when you
listen to a song it's trying to predict
what's the next song when you're
watching a video on YouTube is
predicting the next video to watch
it's everywhere it's impacting every
industry from Real Estate to driving
cars to retail everything and most
people don't understand it right so I
explain exactly how it works and the
whole history of it right so if you want
to understand how AI impacts our life I
I recommend this book right
um and the book is called making things
think and it's how Ai and deep learning
power the products that we use and so uh
um for the parts that I've read so far
it is essentially looking at things that
are already in existence right it's it's
not a pie in the sky Hey one day we're
gonna have uh the singularity and
there's going to be a chip in our brain
and and kind of all that stuff as much
as it's like here is actually
understanding the the uh reality of the
technology today and where you are
interacting with it in your life exactly
yeah if you want to you know think about
what's going to happen in the future I
give you some hints where we're heading
right but I think it's
the most important aspect is to know
what how is impacting your life how is
impacting you today right uh it's going
to impact your industry it's going to
impact your life and you probably should
know how it works right yeah it's um
it's pretty interesting uh to kind of
contemplate all of the different ways
that uh the um all the different ways
that the technology will actually be
integrated into this
um it is uh uh because we don't
understand it all yet right like there's
somebody right now I think a lot about
this there's somebody somewhere in the
world right now who is using this
technology and they're tinkering and
they're trying to explore uh different
ways uh to actually uh implement it in a
certain industry or a certain
application or a product and eventually
they are going to come up with a
breakthrough that then will spread like
wildfire across the entire uh world and
we will all be like wow that was amazing
I can't believe no one ever thought
about that or had ever built uh using
that technology in that way yeah I think
that is great could you imagine that
Bitcoin was created you know like before
that you wouldn't even imagine about
this creation the iPhone you know like
there will be New Creations that we
can't think about it that will have 10
years from now they will impact our
lives like a ton right uh and that's
exciting that's the exciting part of our
Lives yeah it is um it is absolutely uh
uh exciting but also uh I think
something that reminds you like there's
still a lot of work to do yeah and uh if
you think about artificial intelligence
and its ability to go from where we are
to where we want to go uh we're going to
need a hell of a lot of Engineers right
um we're gonna need those Engineers
trained in the latest technology
um and it brings kind of the the
conversation full circle which is uh in
some way uh we are trying to build
technology that will put humans out of
today's jobs to free them up to do other
more productive things and allow the
machines to take over some of the uh
repetitive tasks and and things that
um humans do out of necessity today but
maybe in the future won't have to yeah
uh I think there are two uh industries
that you can have a lot of Leverage and
one of them is media and another one is
you know softer you'll write it once and
then you distribute uh to everyone
um and and the impact everyone's lives
right like everyone has uh you know
Facebook or Instagram and so on their in
their phones everyone has an iPhone or
Android you know they have a smartphone
uh and that impacts everyone's lives uh
it's great because you're you're
basically you know impacting the uh the
whole society and it's usually you know
uh to the good yeah it is um uh uh
something that fascinates me because it
also requires people to be optimistic
about the future yeah uh it is very hard
to build these Technologies and build
these products and be a pessimist right
yeah yeah I mean if you look a hundred
years ago and how our lives were shitty
right like you you can't like
it's hard to not be optimistic about the
future right like they see the iPhone
you know like how our cars evolved if
you look around you know like just look
at our cars the cars that how they look
in the 70s and how they look now
they're so much better so much safer
right
uh medicine keeps improving like
everything keeps improving over time in
average right yeah you have some like
mismanagement in some areas but overall
Society improves over time yeah it is um
uh it's fascinating whenever I see uh
they say machines can identify like
x-rays like problems on x-rays better
than uh than human doctors and stuff
like just things that you would never
have expected uh for machines to be able
to do yeah it's great where can we send
people to find the uh the book yeah you
can go to holloway.com uh the name of
the books making things think Holloway
is a platform where they have different
books they have really great books
um you can go there and then just yeah
buy the digital version of the book
awesome so making things think how Ai
and deep learning power the products
that we use go to Holloway uh the
website to uh to get that and then where
can people find you online if they want
to talk more about these ideas or learn
more yeah you can find me on Twitter I'm
also on firecaster which is this
decentralized uh social network and on
YouTube as well so if you search for
Juliano jacalia which is probably going
to be in the show notes uh you can find
me there awesome well listen thank you
so much for your time today I learned a
lot and I think that people are very
interested in artificial intelligence
machine learning deep learning all this
uh things uh and so hopefully this will
be helpful to the message try to learn
more thank you so much for thanking me
yeah